and they look at me and say you know
this takes like three months or so at
least to do you know all the process
and look i don't have three months i
have like three hours if it's not you
i'm gonna go to the next bank
[Music]
dd horn thank you for joining me on 20
minute leaders all the way from
the east coast right now right yeah
that's correct i'm currently in
pennsylvania and it's so great to be
here thank you for having me
of course i i'm really appreciative that
you're here you know you're
running a startup based out of canada
but with offices also in romania and
and now in israel i believe recently i
saw it on ctec a big announcement
and and what you're doing is truly
fascinating because it really is the
future and i and i personally get so
excited about the companies that are
looking at where where the market needs
to be in you know 5-10 years and how to
add real value with deep technology
and so i i love what you're doing with
uh with unmanned
uh aircraft so diddy without me giving
too much away
tell me a little bit about what you do
and then i'd love to go all the way back
at how you started your whole journey
amazing so skyex founded on 2016
where the main idea was to bring data
from the air or bird's eye view data
from anywhere right to any location at
any given time without
all the complexity that's involved
within this process
uh that currently you have if you
looking for such a
such elements to the ability to track
and to see
everywhere and get it you know on a
website on a dashboard
and use it mainly for commercial market
oil and gas
railways um transmission lines border
patrols all of those
that was really in the in the mindset
when we built the skyx
right so take me back to the pain point
where are we today
in 2020 or or even better where are we
in 2016 when you're saying like wow
there's this whole gap we have this
whole space that we're not able to even
understand why do we need unmanned
aircrafts to
take above footage all right so let me
share with you a secret of the industry
so after
after leaving the air force for almost a
decade full of service
where my last position was in the
headquarters responsible for future
unmanned system whatever they do and
implementation
you know within the military and between
the industries and all that
um i took your time off and like many
other
you know graduate of the israeli service
usually you go to thailand south america
do some some sort of that trip
instead of having that i went to
conferences
and exhibitions of oil and gas right now
i didn't have any clue about the oil and
gas industry at
all and i went to those conferences
because i had you know i got
feeling that if i'll be patient enough
and will sit
on the booth of shell or axon or chevron
all those
giants right that usually they will not
speak to me
but in conference first i would assume
that you know the ceo
or the vps will come to see the
exhibition because they're having a good
time
and they will be very prone to speak
they will prone to sell their product
so i came to them all right and i was
kind of fancy looking with a jacket and
all that
and i was i would describe myself as
having the technology that i envisioned
right i told them what if i have right
now a company based in israel
doing one two three would you you know
it will interest you
uh another time i i shared as kind of
another
fellow oil company small size from
israel other places
and told them that i heard about this
new invention what they think about it
and what strikes me and i really
remember that is
every time i asked this question they
their response was
you know what we have no idea what's
going on on our pipelines
we have no idea how to monitor it and
right now whatever we're using
is very inefficient so if what you have
you really have it that's for sure
something that we would like to have
with
with us so what what is happening
today in the in the oil and gas and you
know all those industries where you have
a bunch of
i'm guessing infrastructure you have a
bunch of a lot of things on the ground
why is it so hard for them to keep
maintenance and
keep an eye on what's happening there
why is it so difficult
so coming from a small country like like
like we do you know from israel
um you think that you know all gas power
plants i don't know 200 300 400
kilometers
equivalent of like 200 miles and you
fairly can engage
you know every every inch of it but
going forward looking at the u.s market
which is probably by far the largest oil
and gas
industry or russia or south america or
africa
you have those lines that has been built
you know
literally a century ago on 1920 to 1950
most of the pipelines have been built
and and they're running all over the
place on very high
you know places that you cannot even
engage you cannot see them so even to
fly
to fly an aircraft like regular airplane
it it takes time it takes logistic
now put aside the fact that let's say
you don't have the capability but let's
say you manage to go through it and you
can fly above with
i don't know cessna or any other
helicopter or whatever that be right
then you need to fly consistently on the
same route
over and over you need to download all
the information right you need to upload
it to a computer you need to translate
it to something and then in the end of
the day
what those companies were getting were
like a notebook
saying i was here i was done that looks
fine now
that's great for a report after an
incident
you know uh to cover yourself all right
so yes i checked that but nobody looked
at it it's like 600 pages report for
whatever
and what i told those companies said
look if i can bring you you don't really
care
what am i flying out there right it
doesn't matter if it's a drone
cessna satellite or spaceship it doesn't
matter right
for you i'm bringing you a photo and i'm
not bringing you a raw
image i'm bringing you an actionable
item meaning you see an image
and it's okay i found this this and that
all right so you know
to send your technicians or your
operator guy
go there fix that you know to prioritize
your issues
so even those giants companies with
really budgets that
we cannot understand right like they can
own countries if they want to
um they were looking to efficient way
to save money not in three years time
but tomorrow morning
and and we believe that with our product
um we managed to bring it
far in advance than any other company so
they don't really care that it's
a drone that it's this deep technology
thing they don't care if there's a
person there or
or if it's nothing all they care about
is that then they get better
images and better actionable items than
whatever their current solution is which
could be manpower it could be
helicopters it could be whatever right
but but
but really the what i what i'm getting
excited about here which is the
technology that's not even
what you're selling to to these
companies right
so someone told someone told me someone
told me in the past you know
i i love airplanes i don't know from you
know days i was a kid and to the air
force obviously
and you know our drone that we built
in-house is probably the coolest you can
get
but that's only gets you through the
door right
that's the excited by that so they say
okay oh my god this is a drone company
let's bring them over
as soon as i walk inside the door and
i'm sitting on the first meeting with
the company i said look
you see this school drone that's the
last time you will see it
my responsibility is you will never get
to see it anymore any time again because
you want to consume data you don't care
what am i flying that's my issue that's
not none of your business
you stay focused on your own now again
bear in mind those companies has
you know fleet of jets they have fleet
of airplanes for themselves
they don't care for the money right they
care
every time that you bring system to
shell or chevron or those giants
you need to train everyone from the top
to the bottom
on that's you know sophisticated uh a
system
and when i can't come to them and say
hey you know what put all that aside
you get picture to your screen that's it
you don't care
what do i do to create those picture to
your screen that's basically what we
provide them
so how do you balance them as an
entrepreneur
running a startup at the end that is
growing but it is a startup and
you know a lot of the times you hear
focus focus focus so how do you balance
focusing on building this drone that
needs to do this very complicated
behavior
which we don't see today in in the skies
right i was just
the other day i was lying on on the
television beach before the lockdown of
course with my girlfriend and we're
we saw this helicopter we said wow how
is it possible that there's only one
vehicle in the sky right now what's
going to be in 10 years so so on one end
you're building that technology
on the other hand you're educating the
market and you have to go and sell
you know software to these companies in
in a way that they're actually going to
enjoy so how do you focus on these two
things
equally to bring that solution so we did
uh two things or i decided very early on
to to take two routes
um i understood that you know the drones
like you say
can be applicable to probably any
industry and like i started with
we can be relevant to turn transmission
line and railways and and border patrol
and everything you can mention that is
long distance infrastructure that
currently doesn't have such solution
and i decided from all of those i think
the oil and gas market will be the first
one to adopt
such technology and the main reason for
it is because
they have the lines they already are
outside urban areas
which make the regulator or the country
more favorable to approve
flight outside the city to protect this
you know citizens from
potential leak or spills or theft of oil
than to approve it to fly you know
downtown manhattan
above some some you know people on the
streets right that's probably uh um
fast ever out the second thing that that
we choose
is that we're not selling hardware we're
selling
data as a service right like software's
a service but that data as a service
and when we come to the customer say
those awesome hardwares that we
creating in-house because currently
nobody else
know how to create and we did it and we
signed patents on it
still you pay data as a service and when
you pay that as a service for them
it's like you and i using gmail and we
don't know
have no clue how many servers google you
know maintaining
so you and i can open gmail every day
and we'll have our emails every day
that's what we were trying to sell them
is there a cool
factor by the fact that you're saying
yeah look i'm selling you data but
really
look i have there's this really awesome
drone that is collecting it is that
does that give you an edge is that
relevant at all i think the idea that
we're really
getting is that the fact that you have
those this autonomous drone
that can fly really remote like we fly
we flew drones from toronto
above the skies of mexico right or the
other side of canada
like the guys sitting in toronto um
the fact that you can do that and have
the drones fly over and over and over
and again and create this database
that eventually will turn this data to
what we call the big data
and will provide the customer predictive
analytics
but even the predictive analytics
meaning is that you know
i i i flew above about above this line
i found something next day i started
this thing this hole in the ground
got expanded and then expanded again now
i can take this
drive that to the customer and say look
if you don't take any action tomorrow
this is the size of the whole gonna get
this predictive analytics
is valuable information that nobody can
provide to you
i'll give you one more example a quick
example we did a project with uh with uh
with company in canada here i cannot uh
share the name but huge company in
canada
and that was during the pandemic and
they asked us to fly above some houses
they approved to fly above houses
and see that you know everything is
going smooth with the line
and we we flew once a week so we flew
one time we saw a house
the next week we saw nothing and then
the next week we saw another house
so in canada it's very common to you
know this distract your house and build
a new one kind of you know renovations
and
it can take literally two weeks to do it
but what we found
is that what the difference was that now
he did dig a hole
to build a basement beneath the ground
what he didn't know
is the pipeline of oil that runs all the
way to toronto
going underneath his house so that's
something that's so valuable that you
cannot track by
you know men going to state taking
pictures or cessna that fly one time you
need something
consistent that will fly every day of
the week
wow no that that's that that's really
really interesting why canada why
romania
i i know a lot of servers that started
in tel aviv you served for 10 years
in the israeli air force you're from
israel i know a lot of companies of
israelis that go to
san francisco and palo alto not too much
of canada so
what's happening over there true so so
let me tell you that i found toronto as
one of the greatest tech hubs
um that i think right now is evolving i
think much much faster than
palo alto and san francisco and probably
new york los angeles
the hub like this they really take
serious care about
startups around here and that's that's
very nice to see but when i got here
that was not the reason we looked for a
country that has
significant amount of uh long
infrastructures
such oil and gas very progressive
regulation
towards drones and fly drones and kind
of western economy
and unfortunately in israel right now to
fly drones freely
is fairly hard because you know we're a
small country and the air force kind of
control everything and everything is so
operational and you need to be very
defense oriented
um in canada there is you know huge
amount of space
where nobody leaves and there is
pipelines and we knew
that that to approve flight above those
routes would be much easier than to fly
you know
near tel aviv or something like that
right that makes sense and then romania
so so eastern europe and it's not just
romania we open mainly from software
developers like we do right now in in
israel we found great talents
and i think on on on cost
versus the performance that we're
getting from them they are
really really great guys that we found
really talented
and different approach that we liked um
you know palo alto better than me and
the rates there for software developer
are crazy
probably second to that is only israel
so we needed to find some you know as a
startup to find some
economy on that we have an office in in
the u.s that is
mainly towards sales sales and marketing
in the us
and our intention is over in the future
to open another office in the uae
looking to have something some
partnership and sell to the gcc area
because we believe that's another
culture another market that we want to
expand to
i love that so tell me a little bit
about you about your
entrepreneurial journey what are some of
the the you know the biggest challenges
that maybe you face whether it's
you know emotionally or or you know
mentally intellectually with
with building such a complicated concept
right so it's not just another
you know mobile app it's really you know
a
big big you know operational supply
chain that you're that you're providing
here
what are some of the craziest challenges
that you've had to overcome
so you asked about canada and and as
soon as
this idea i brought it to uh investors
and they were agreed to that and they
saw it as actually good for the company
i found myself right with 1.5 million us
dollar as a kind of seed round
sent to canada where i visit the first
time
don't know how to open business don't
know how to create a team
don't know how to open a business
account in you know canadian bank
and i remember one one event in in
specifically when i
when i get into one of the largest uh um
banks in canada called cibc
and i'm entering the front door on on
the on the main branch in downtown
saying hey i'm new in town i'm opening a
business here i need to transfer money i
need to open a business
etc etc and they're looking at me and
you know i'm kind of an immigrant
i have not no credit report i have no
account with them they don't know me
and they look at me and say you know
this takes like three months or so at
least to do you know all the process
and look i don't have three months i
have like three hours if it's not you
i'm gonna go to the next bank
and the next thing happened is that you
know the manager of the bank came to me
and i'm like nothing and like no one
nobody knows me right
no whatever and and things moving and
and the greatest challenge to find
yourself
with this heavy lift on your shoulder
not to fundraise for your vision
because that's hard but the point in
time
always when i finish around and you get
the money in the bank and all of a
sudden
you know what now you don't have any
excuses you have all the money you
requested
go ahead make it happen i think that's
the greatest challenge for an
entrepreneur
for me it was added to the to the
ability to mix the culture of israelis
and canadians and create a match
of a great team and great talent and
know to appreciate each one
culture and benefit from it
right i think a lot of i hear a lot of
people talking about how you know
fundraising is one of the most difficult
jobs of of the entrepreneur and the ceo
but really it is the day after
now you have the money in the bank and
now you're saying okay well now what now
i have all this responsibility
from my customers from my investors for
my employees
how do i execute on this vision that i
just sold both to bring myself to the
next round but to actually you know
execute on on the things that i said and
which leads me i think to
the most interesting question here what
what is in store for
first tax and where do you see the world
in you know five
ten years in terms of the the problems
that you're trying to face
whether it's through skyx or any other
competitor that may rise
so really in the mindset of skype is not
to provide services to
one company or another beat the oil and
gas company or on any other company
in the mindset of skylax is really to
provide a useful information from the
air
in the accessibility that every person
can can get to so if tomorrow you want
to build your house
you enter into some website let's call
it skyx.com
and you say okay i want to see this area
for the past i don't know three months
or how it's going to look like for the
next three months and you just order
photos of this area now it sounds like
okay that's nice to have i don't really
need it's true
but if you are infrastructure like huge
infrastructure you do need that you
consume this data
so our goal is to get in probably two to
three years time to ability to track at
least 50 to 100 000 kilometer
on daily basis once you have access to
000 kilometers on daily basis you know
you can save animals from unauthorized
poaching in africa
you can find lost childs in the forest
in canada we did it once
you can track so many like the fires in
san francisco as they happen
and determine where do you need to find
to send the fire teams
before the fire ignite and not after
all this valuable information that we
know to appreciate in our daily life you
know to our
phones and and watches and it's not
that's not exist on bird's eye view so
we think that we
already proved and still proving for the
next two years
the ability to make this happen and very
efficient means and we're hoping that by
then we'll be
contracting or partnering or growing to
scale it 10 times
10 times as much to a point where you
can spread it
you know really across the globe uh
i just love that vision didi thank you
so much for being so generous with your
time this was just wonderful
uh before we leave i have to ask the
most important question which is three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
it's probably the toughest one um of
course
determined unforgivable and always
dreaming
i love that dd thank you so so much this
was just wonderful
and stay safe and stay healthy i look
forward to seeing what happens with sky
x it was amazing thank you very much for
your time
take care thank you